you ever just call your dad up and go
hey dad how's it going did you kill any
kids today no well that's because your
dad isn't asgore from undertale now if
you know the story of undertale then you
know that he had his reasons for killing
human children
like trying to save all of monster kind
but regardless of whether you love him
or hate him after the fact ultimately
that was undertale it's all about
deltaroo now toby fox's shiny new
story-driven rpg that why do you mean
it's over three years old toby fox's new
were rpg that features a completely
different world with mostly all the same
people see pretty much everyone from
undertale has made a reappearance in
deltarune at this point from the biggest
ones like toriel sans and papa asgore to
even some small characters like the
politics bear now there are plenty of
theories out there about how the
universe of delterine is connected to
the universe of undertale or why it's
not connected in contrast if you're
interested in my take on the matter
check out my previous and also first
delterin theory i did on the channel
about the genocide timeline i'll link to
it in the description below anyway what
i wanted to focus on for this theory is
one recurring character in particular
asgore the sorrowful king of the
monsters but wait like i mentioned
earlier that was his undertale
appearance in deltarune as we've seen
now for over three years asgore is kind
of different similar to his previous
iteration he's still unable to hold down
a happy marriage apparently as we see he
and toriel are divorced by the time we
get to play the game but he's no longer
a king or leader of any sort i mean he
used to be the town's chief of police
but he got let go for some unknown
reason and now runs a flower store
that's cheekily called the flower king
where he also lives on a little air
mattress guest toriel got to keep the
house in the split and speaking of
toriel while the game doesn't tell us
yet at least why she and asgore got the
divorce there are definitely several
details we can pick up on already for
instance asgore talks to chris about
toriel quite a bit and even has her
picture on his fridge in contrast toriel
never mentions asgore unless provoked to
like when asgore sent a bouquet of
flowers tutorial via his child chris
urging chris to keep the source of the
flowers secret since he knew that toriel
most likely wouldn't have accepted them
if she knew who they were from but he
still wanted her to have some anonymous
flowers all the same just to see her
smile toriel caught on pretty quickly
though as to where they were from and
after referring to asgore as him throws
the fresh bouquet away in the trash can
do tutorials civil behavior as opposed
to asgore's constant reaching out we can
deduce that the divorce was most likely
initiated by toriel was most likely over
something she felt was morally wrong in
an extreme and unforgivable way and was
most likely something that happened not
too long ago since her feelings are
still rather fresh like those flowers in
the trash can in addition to asgore's
relationship with toriel going down the
drain he was also fired from his job as
chief of police which is a pretty highly
esteemed position to have once again we
don't know the circumstances of why he
got removed from work but there are a
few pieces of evidence that we can
deduce from the situation as a whole in
the first place i personally highly
doubt that asgore was terminated as a
police chief due to poor conduct or poor
performance reason why is he's just so
nice okay i mean look at how he hugs his
child and in addition to his giving
toriel flowers not even wanting her to
know who from he also apparently keeps
giving flowers to lots of people for
free and because of this is unable to
pay rent on his business's building
slash home and is about to be evicted
and homeless as well as businessless the
monster man is clearly a man of the
people who cares deeply for those around
him at his own expense plus he wouldn't
have even been able to get the chief of
police position in the first place if he
hadn't have shown great conduct as a
regular police officer beforehand
because of this i tend to think that
there was a big thing like one specific
event that took place that resulted in
his getting fired from work and undone
getting promoted early to fill his shoes
and it was probably not a very good
event now between getting divorced and
losing his esteemed job you could
probably imagine that asgore isn't
having a very good time but fortunately
his tragic backstory details stop there
i tend to assume that both of these
tragedies in asgore's past are connected
and even though it's mostly just an
assumption i do have one detail backing
it up in chapter 2 if chris enters the
police department and reads one of the
articles on the wall behind undyne we
can see some details that reconfirm
asgore's sudden removal and undyne's
sudden rookie promotion but then chris
suddenly decides to stop reading now
you've got to ask yourself why would
chris stop reading about their own
father's story to me this implies that
there is some emotional pain involved in
reading the story while it could be just
the pain of reading about your father
getting fired i think it's probably a
bit deeper than that like it probably
implies that whatever happened with
asgore also affected asgore's family the
dreamers if this is true and it brought
up some bad memories for chris that they
decided to not fully recall at the time
of reading then i'm sure whatever
happened has also affected toriel and
therefore probably had something to do
with their divorce as well and that's
what i'm going with believing until toby
fox decides to reveal something else to
us on that note you might be thinking
this is cool and all but there's no way
we can determine what happened to asgore
in the past right since chris won't read
any further and nobody else says
anything in the entire game and you'd be
right at least as far as deltarune is
concerned remember that these characters
are all somewhat parallels of their
undertale counterparts alphys was a
scientist in undertale now she's a
teacher in deltarune undyne was a
protector warrior loyal to the monsters
and asgore and now she's a protector
police officer who was loyal to asgore
before taking his place toriel was mama
goat and now she's still mama goat and
sans is just sans see how even though
everyone is different now they're still
kind of doing the same things in a weird
parallel sort of way if we apply this to
asgore it fits as well since he was the
king of the monsters in undertale who
swore to protect his people and in
deltarune he was the king of the police
if you will who by definition also swore
to protect his town's people but there
was one other detail about undertale
asgore that i mentioned at the start of
the video remember how he used to kill
children in undertale now i'm not saying
he's a child murderer and delterin
necessarily but let's piece some other
things together and see what comes up
ask yourself who in the entire town
would be able to fire the chief of
police it wouldn't be the chief's
underlings like undyne or napstablook it
wouldn't be the people rioting to take
him out because i'm pretty sure that
would have been a big story and he
wouldn't be a part of the town anymore
so wouldn't it be the mayor of the town
whose job is to oversee the people's
public servants like police officers i
think that the only logical conclusion
as to who gave the order to remove
asgore from his police chief position
probably came from the mayor herself and
as of chapter 2 it was confirmed to us
via alphys that the mayor of the town is
a neighbor to chris meaning she is none
other than noelle's mother and rudolph's
wife and as some of you already know
mayor holliday just so happens to have a
missing daughter des holiday short for
december noelle's older sister we've
never met or even seen us in game but
from what we can gather from noelle's
dialogue and suzie's reaction to the
death doll in rudy's hospital room we
can determine that something bad
probably happened to des leading to her
disappearance from the town something
that might have even resulted in her
death i say this because we know that
death doesn't live at home since when
noel lost her keys in chapter one
nobody's home to let her in and given
what we've heard about des being
extremely protective of her little
sister i highly doubt that she would
just run away and leave her little
sister put up with their overbearing
mother who everyone does admit is quite
hard on the girls could there be a link
between asgore's removal from the police
force and dece's probable death given
that the kids chris asriel december and
noel used to be very close but grew
apart after des disappearance implying
something happened to cause a rift
between the two families and that
asgore's parallel counterpart was
responsible for the deaths of children
in undertale i could see something that
dark resulting in toriel's hatred of her
ex-husband and decision to ultimately
divorce him the question is what could
have happened that resulted in des death
involving asgore the chief of police i
will say this much
i'm not really sure but i have a couple
of guesses it's possible that there was
just some tragic accident that asgore
was somehow involved in that resulted in
mayor and toriel blaming him for des
death but rudy asgore's best friend
ended up forgiving him as we can see
since rudy speaks highly of asgore
whenever you go talk to him in the
hospital after all he and asgore are
best friends and it must have been an
accident although the details of what
that might have been are pretty much
completely unknowable at this point i do
have one other guest though which is
much much more speculative but i'm gonna
say it anyway so consider yourself
forewarned as of chapter 2 we know that
noel is extremely powerful to say the
least the alternate route called the
snow grave route that can be taken in
the library dark world reveals to us
that she is capable of controlling cold
weather when she's under intense stress
and ultimately can cast the powerful
snow grave blizzard while blacking out
strangely if we visit the convenience
store we can hear from this individual
standing here that the quote hoofed girl
also known as noel has been coming into
the store and staring at the frozen
section for some time now meaning that
for an unknown amount of time she's had
this strange affinity for the cold and
if we talk to catty at the diner she
reveals that she's taught occult spells
to noel proving that magic does exist
outside of the dark world and she also
says that noel has recently been quote
slipping into the darkness now hear me
out what if noel once cast snowgrave the
powerful blizzard-like spell in real
life with dire consequences which earned
its name snow grave we know that noel
and the rest of the kids used to play in
the forest around the graveyard and that
it used to scare noelle who would
sometimes cry and wipe her tears on
asriel's jacket well what if in one of
these scary times the stress got to noel
and she blacked out and cast snow grave
like she did in the dark world and it
caused a terrible blizzard to happen in
the forest which asriel and chris were
able to escape from but what if noel and
her sister were still caught somewhere
inside snowgrave which prompted the
police chief asgore and noel's father
rudy to try to rescue them from but they
were not able to find the girls in the
storm and rudy started to become deeply
affected by the extreme cold nearing
death himself and seeing his best friend
dying in their endless search for the
girls which could have resulted in
everybody dying if he did nothing asgore
decided to call the surge off in order
to save the life of his best friend who
due to his close brush with near-death
by cold contracted an extreme case of
pneumonia and is still hospitalized to
this day coughing violently all the
while and after the storm ended asgore
was able to recover noel who was immune
to snowgrave's effects but tragically
found december's lifeless body in the
aftermath the pain of losing a daughter
due to the chief of police calling off
the rescue caused mayor holliday to fire
asgore and toriel who in undertale left
asgore because she believed him to be a
coward decided to divorce him again in
deltarune due to believing he was a
coward for abandoning the rescue this
explains why she apparently hates him
still and why asgore keeps sending
flowers to rudy and why rudy doesn't
blame asgore for what happened since he
knows his friend was saving his life and
didn't want anybody to die it also
explains why noel has no memory of the
event and why chris would know about
noelle's power and force her to her
limit in the snow grave route since
there is no reason chris should have any
idea of why or how that could happen in
the first place unless chris had seen
the power before of course this is all
just my theory though but you've gotta
admit given how little we know of
asgore's past in deltarune currently
this is a pretty good way of tying
everything together and explaining rudy
mayor des noel toriel chris and of
course asgore's background but what do
you guys think though is asgore involved
in the mysterious disappearance of
december holiday or is it still a
complete mystery until toby fox and team
decides otherwise let me know in the
comments below also huge thanks for
watching this is my second delta in
theory on the channel and both of them
have been so much fun to make but i
wouldn't have made the second one if it
wasn't for you guys and the great
turnaround on the first video so thank
you once again so much please consider
leaving a like on this video to get it
spread around on youtube and subscribe
to the channel for much more gaming
stuff to come huge thanks of course to
my bandit crew of which i have some
amazing new names to announce say hello
to dragon lacer rachel g murray the
awesome and a big big hello to classical
revisionist who joined not once but
twice on the top level in patreon i
don't know what to say classical
revisionist and the rest of the bandit
crew new and old seriously thank you
guys so much for your support i'm
humbled and excited to keep bringing you
the content that you're apparently a fan
of love you guys and i think that about
wraps up everything i've got for this
video as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is mass
nintendo bandit looking forward to
seeing you next time and signing out
peace
[Music]
you